[Music]
looks like you'll have to wait a while
longer for mr. Rosetti to shout at you
on your commute to work I'm Dave and
welcome to your G s news update
a Nintendo has confirmed that animal
Crossing's mobile entry has been delayed
until the next financial year
that means the game's release could fall
any time between April 1st 2017 and
March 31st 2018 the game was actually
due to launch in the first quarter of
this year the reason for the delay is to
accommodate both Fire Emblem heroes and
Super Mario run Fire Emblem Heroes
launches for every second while Super
Mario run launch for iOS at December
15th and is due out on Android in March
this year this is an animal Crossing's
first mobile delay it was originally
meant to come out in 2016
speaking with GameSpot Nintendo director
Shigeru Miyamoto said entender will
continue to focus on crafting original
games to mobile rather than porting old
ones
I don't think we'll take the past mario
games that we've made and just move them
over to a mobile platform if you want
some mobile mario to keep you going you
can check out our review on Super Mario
run and if you have any battery left
after that remember to like the video
and subscribe to GameSpot
[Music]